il faut le dire le principe est simple
on va revenir chaque semaine sur les
tweets qui ont fait le plus de buzz sur
X et on aura même parfois l'auteur du
tweet en question avec nous sur ce
plateau pour débattre face à N face à
nos chroniqueurs il y a une vidéo qui a
beaucoup buzzé d'ailleurs sur X cette
semaine c'est celle de Ramza il raconte
un entretien qui s'est plutôt mal passé
regardez
entretien avec le patron là Z c'était le
boss il me dit franchement l'aidere de
motivation nickel CV nickel depuis tout
à l'heure je parle avec vous vous avez
l'air de être une bonne personne nickel
tout est bien mais il y a une chose si
vous venez bosser ici faut que vous
changez votre prénom sur la porte nom et
prénom mais vous savez comment il s'est
justifié il a dit les personnes avec qui
vous allez travailler ils ont certain
âge ils sont encore arriérés et ils sont
pas encore prêts à accepter des ordres
d'une personne d'origine
étrangère alors euh cette histoire est
incroyable est-ce que vous êtes déjà
arrivé vous voilà alors je sais pas
discrimination ici vous ça m' arrivé une
fois qu'on me demande mais de manière
subtile si j'avais prévu de faire des
enfants dans les mois qui venent qui
allaient venir ah ouais ouais c'est vrai
c'est ça oui bah ça se fait pas c'est
une forme de discrimination non mais ça
fait pas c'était vraiment ça manquait ça
manquait beaucoup de TAAC et puis
c'était j'ai tout de suite compris ce
qu'il voulait dire quoi parce que si
c'est le cas en gros on vous prend pas
quoi Carla moi on m' appelé Carla
[Rires]
Baya
franchement c'est la meilleure van de
l'émission F on fera pas mieux ce soir
alors Ramza victime de discrimination à
l'embauche il va venir nous rejoindre
applaudissement pour lui
merci merci merci d'être
là merci d'être là merci alors ta vidéo
elle a énormément buzé ton poste aussi
malgré son bac bac plus 5 il a quelqu'un
qui a dit sa bonne volonté ce maghrébin
était discriminé à l'embauche en raison
de son nom car les Français ne désirent
pas être dirigés par un étranger lui a
ton prétexté on lui a suggéré de changer
de nom et de prénom c'est assez fou tu
as quel âge Ramza 27 ans 27 ans tu as
fait quoi comme étude j'ai un master 2
stratégie commerciale ouais Master 2
pour moi c'est un un centre commercial
donc B+ 5 B + 5 et ouais bac + 5 Master
2 B + 5 de quoi stratégie commerciale
fort ah ouais donc là tu tu veux faire
quoi en fait c'est quoi pour faire pour
devenir quoi là actuellement je suis
créateur de contenu d'accord j'ai fait
une reconversion tu cherches tu
cherchais un travail depuis depuis quand
je ne cherche plus de travailant avant
avant avant quand tu as fait le quand tu
as fait je cherchais une alternance
d'accord euh valider ma 5e année cet
entretien c'était le seul retour que tu
as eu ou bien tu en avais eu d'autres
non j'ai eu d'autres entretiens qui se
sont très très bien passés par la suite
tu as senti là-dessus que ton ton nom
posait problème pas dès le début ouis
pas dès le début dès le début j'ai passé
premier entretien franchement très très
bien passé deuxème entretien aussi trème
entretien aussi donc on a validé mes
compétences bien sû ouais ouais et
ensuite euh bah le 4e aussi s'est très
très bien passé jusqu'à ce qu'on fasse
cette demande attends tu as passé quatre
entretiens dans la même entreprise C je
les ai jamais vu
moi je les rencontre ici non mais on est
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous y croyez
à l'histoire moi j'y crois à ton
histoire franchement est-ce que vous y
croez est-ce qu'il y en a qui croi pas
Gill Verz j'y crois totalement quand on
a un prénom à consonance maghrébine on a
31 % de chance en moins d'être contacté
par un chasseur de tête Suan pour
l'stant exactement tour non mais c'est
vrai si je m'appelais Suleiman je serais
obligé de changer de prénom pour avoir
un job c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui est dramatique en France
pas d'accord non mais je trouve que ça
sent un peu le roussi cette histoire ça
sent le rousi parce que en fait ce que
je comprends pas mais peut-être vous
allez m'éclairer vous arrivez donc vous
faites les quatre entretiens déjà dans
la vidéo vous dites alors un de alors là
trois entretiens comme si c'était relié
en fait à votre origine alors qu'en fait
je sais pas si vous avez fait beaucoup
d' de de vous avez recherché beaucoup de
travail dans la vie mais quatre
entretiens c'est totalement normal dans
toutes les entreprises et ensuite on
vous dit qu'il faut changer de prénom
parce que les gens ne sont pas prêts à
être dirigés par quelqu'un donc
d'origine arabe mais alors déjà vous
êtes alternant vous allez diriger qui et
puis de deux je dire les gens ils vont
le voir sans sans voilà vous pouvez vous
appeler pierre mais on verra que vous
avez quelqu d'origine vous voyez ce que
jeux dire donc pourquoi enfin à la
limite il vous demande de changer de
tête alors je vais vous expliquer une
chose c'est la première fois que je
passais quatre entretiens dans une
entreprise
c'est pour ça que je l'ai exprimé de
cette manière que je trouvais ça assez
long mais vous savez que lorsqu'on est
dans une recherche d'alternance on est
prêt à tout on se dit voilà il faut que
je valide ma 5e année j'ai vraiment
envie je suis motivé premier entretien
d'accord 2ème entretien ok 4è entretien
il y a pas de souci vraiment il y a
aucun souci j'ai pas trouvé ça long je
suis prêt à tout pour trouver une
alternance à ce moment-là d'accord
ensuite c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai
fait pour que j'ai raconté c'est plus
pour essayer de sensibiliser ça de de
cette manière là pour essayer de
sensibiliser les gens et surtout de
montrer que voilà c'est une réalité mais
qu'il faut aller de l'avant mais je
comprends bien mais pour pourquoi
changer de prénom pourquoi dans dans
dans l'imaginaire de cet employeur
changer de prénom aller tout changer si
c'était sur une base de racisme mais
Juli fa pas Tom de l'ARM pardon mais il
y a notamment des plateformes
téléphoniques dont la personne au
téléphone elle s'appelle Julie alors que
tu sais qu'en fait elle ne s'appelle pas
Julie donc c'est bien une réalité ce ce
jeune homme a été confronté rité moi je
faisais de la vente par téléphone je
disais jamais C
Hanouna Ivan rouegorge je que c'est vrai
un nom d'oiseau je m'van rougeegorge oui
j ouais moi moi ce qui me gêne dans dans
la vidéo et et le message c'est que vous
faites un amalgame et vous vous essayez
de sensibiliser sur une discrimination
qui pour moi est exagérée il peut y
avoir de la discrimination à l'embauche
ça exist ça existe toujours très
clairement il peut y avoir du racisme il
peut y avoir des chef d'entreprisees qui
n'ont pas envie de recruter tel ou tel
profil très bien mais de là à dire que
aujourd'hui en France en 2024 il y a un
mur qui empêche tous nos compatriotes
d'origine étrangère de réussir de
devenir ministre parce que on a la
chance encore une fois aujourd'hui
d'avoir des ministres qui sont
d'origines étrangèr qui ont toutes les
religions de faire de grandes carrières
d'avoir des responsabilités nationales
internationales on est un pays qui
permet tout d' je vais vous dire
d'ailleurs petite info celui qui a eu le
poste c'est pas P
dier
il a été recyclé là-bas ou c'est ou on a
une pensée pour lui
d'ailleurs pas s ou juste aminer c'est
ça qui me gêne voilà après sur les
entretiens c'est normal il y a
énormément d'entreprises où on fait
plusieurs entretiens et là pour le coup
il y a pas de discrimination à
l'embauche on vous a pas dit dès le
départ non vous avez un profil qui nous
intéresse pas vous avez un nom qui nous
intéresse pas il y a une spécificité qui
vous a été demandée alors certes vous la
trouvez dégradante infamante ça je peux
le comprendre il y a aucun souci mais de
là à dire qu'il y a un problème en
France je ne le crois pas moi pour moi
il excusez-moi je vais terminer sur un
point pour moi a juste a juste il y a un
problème de discrimination géographique
vous avez des jeunes de la ruralité qui
eux sont pénalisés à l'embauche parce
qu'ils viennent d'un territoire qui est
enclavé et qui n'ont pas aussi la même
origine gographique mais cela on en
parle beaucoup moins alors r aprè non
mais moi je suis halluciné parce que
j'ai l'impression en plus il connaît les
réalités du terrain Julien aoule donc je
suis outré par ce que vous que ce ce que
vous racontez il y a une chose qui est
clair et et donc dès qu'on parle
d'ailleurs de ce sujet là on nous oppose
la ruralité mais pour revenir au vrai
sujet je vais vous donner un chiffre
très simple 95
% des jeunes qui ne trouvent pas de
stage ou de formation ont un nom à
consonance maghrébine ou Afrique
subsaharienne ce sont les études qui ont
été il y a eu un article il y a il y a 3
semaines de ça dans Le Parisien ce n'est
pas moi qui le dis au-delà de ça nous
qui travaillons sur le terrain depuis
des années vous savez pourquoi il y a
vous connaissez le département dans
lequel il y a le plus de création
d'entreprise c'est voilà vous savez
pourquoi parce que justement il vient de
vous dire une chose que vous n'avez pas
vous avez pas lu entre les lignes il a
dit à un moment donné j'ai changé
d'orientation vous savez pour il y a
énormément de gens de jeunes qui
finissent par faire ça parce qu'il
s'appelle Mamadou il s'appelle Mohamed
c'est une réalité quand vous ne le vivez
pas je peux comprendre que vous ne
compreniez pasnormément je s j
Abdou c'est bon
donc de voter chéri est-ce que vous
êtesv d'accord avec le coup de gueule de
de Ramza oui non vous pouvez voter juste
le Juliette et Julien en fait c'est même
combat c'est-à-dire on devrait dire que
le racisme n'existe plus et c'est pas un
problème si
autant vous remettez en cause le
témoignage ça c'est déjà si si enfin
vous vous le remettez en cause parce que
vous dites il y a peut-être quand même
c'est pas clair enfin moi je trouve que
déjà il a pas fait une théorie politique
il a fait un témoignage et oui ça existe
j'ai dit que ça existait oui mais enfin
la manière dont vous le présentez euh
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de compassion
et de le dire et moi je vous en remercie
c'est quelque chose qui déclenche
justement des questionnements et qui
fait qu'il faut qu' qu'on ne peut plus
autant on peut pas nier le racistme
antiblanc autant on peut pas nier non
plus ce qui vous est arrivé ce qui
existe et qui est très courant et ce
contre quoi parce que là on est en train
de piétiner tous les jeunes qui se
battent parfois dans les quartiers avec
des conditions quand même plus
difficiles comme en ruralité parce que
l'ascenseur sociale en ruralité moi je
ne les oppose pas ment plusile je lesose
pas forcment pas forcément plus
difficile mais pardon avec plus d'argent
public plus de soutien associatif plus
de
médiateurs y a quelque chose qui vous a
énormément déservi dans cette histoire
et c'est la vidéo et c'est sur la vidéo
votre manière de vous exprimer et de
vous d'être habillé en fait vous parlez
de travail d'un entretien d'embauche et
vous vous le faites en fait dans un
style qui est très peu en même temps
vous êtes pas à l'entretien je comprends
pas aidé ça fait pas très
réine envie de vous bien sûr bien sûr il
y a pas de souci j'ai une réponse pour
vous vous savez moi je suis créateur de
contenu j'ai des partenariats à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je suis rémunéré pour
porter ces vêtements là là actuellement
je sais que j'allais au sport je
comprends je vais pas m'habiller en
costume ce qu'il faut que vous
compreniez c'est que
nous on a une on a on a quelque chose on
sait s'adapter ça vous ne savez pas vous
savez pas littéralement la défense la la
la la définition de de s'adapter quand
on va au sport notre tenue s'adapte
lorsqu'on va un entretien notre tenue
s'adapte et lorsqu'on va un mariage
aussi d'accord mais comme tout le monde
en faitou exactement reproch me reprochz
repr
actuellement l'inititive de faire une
vidéo pour parlerut vous plus
présentable sur
Vié moment où je fais ma St je suis
décontracté je au sport et faire ce
genre de raccourci là ça fait ramener de
division est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec le coup de gueule de Ramza moi j'ai
deux choses à dire déjà honnêtement j'en
ai j'en ai assez de voir des personnes
se victimiser oh
là expliquer pouri je vous expliquer
pourquoi
je je vais vous expliquer pourquoi ma
mère est d'origine algérienne mes
grands-parents sont venus d'Algérie
pendant l'indépendance ils ont galéré
mon grand-père était ouvrier ils ont
tous réussi à réussi pardon à avoir des
emplois convenabl à réussir mais
justement à l'épo av plus R avec les
Juifs AC les mags et avec les Africains
aussi mais ce que je veux dire c'est
plutôt que don de donner cette image
parce que là vous êtes là mais arrêtez
de donner cette image aux Arabes arrêtez
c'est vous vous victimisez et en plus
essayez de trouver de solutions surtout
qu'en plus aujourd'hui pour tout le
monde c'est compliqué de trouver du
travail pour tous les pour tout toutes
les personnes qui font des masters c'est
compliqué de trouver un métier et vous
vous mettez dans une posture de victime
les blancs sont les méchants et
nous
parle de discrimination parle de
victimisation AR la victimisation
d'ailleurs je vis rebondir sur
un on ne vous demande pas de vous
adapter on vous demande de vous
assimiler c'est pas la même
chose va lu répondre répondre alors déjà
je suis français pour commencer pas cont
prère chose première chose deuxième
chose vous dites
Z vous qui
dités
m
fr-o 2 minutes 2 minutes vous dites bien
outfit vous dites
bienb
biened
granded oui mais désolé mais le mélange
le mélange du français et de l'anglais
ça vous dérange pas mais le mélange
français et de l'Arab ça vous
Dér dans ce CASL votre argument il
marche
pas ensite vous m'avez reproché quoi de
Me victimiser non désolé je me victimise
pas je je je je témoig juste simplement
d'une d'une expérience professionnelle
simplement je ne dis pas que tout le
monde est comme ça la preuve derrière
j'ai j'ai rebondi j'ai retrouvé une
alternance je ne dis pas que tout le
monde tout le monde ne va pas trouver de
travail du tout j'essaie d'encourager
tous les jours si vous suivez mon
contenu je vous invite à le faire que
voilà tous les jours il faut travailler
il faut aller étudier à l'école comme m'
éduqué mes parents aussi mais pourquoi
vous mettez tous les
magrb je mets aucun mag
dans Je juste j'ai juste mis en lumière
le fait que voilà à l'heure actuelle il
y a de la discrimination il faut faire
avec mais faut surtout avancer c'est
juste ça le
message onlire totalement C alors entre
Juliette qui veut qu'il enlève sa
casquette et
lui'assil julienou élu de la République
non mais vous êes non non vous êtes élu
de la r vousz un
électrochite les gars il est sous élect
je suis ton fantasme je suis ton
fantasme mais dans cette émission c'est
SP il pas bien va nous faire un truc
alors respectable élu de la République
vous votez les lois la loi contre les
discriminations c'est maintenant 3 ans
de prison pourquoi ça a été durci parce
que des gens comme lui ne trouve pas de
boulot et vous nous opposez la ruralité
mais
monsieurouurouz dans
si laance
auourd'i si vous vous appeliez mais si
vous vous appeliez SMAN vous n'auriez
pas de travail vous ne seriez pas député
arrêtez de délirer mais vous êtes dans
un autre monde
quoi qu à vous B mais ça va pas bien
quoi est-ce qu'on peut donner ses
médicaments à Gill Verdez il a des des
mé on pe a deux personnes BL il vont
g Verdez vous avez pas vu la composition
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a des
Souleiman il y a des Français d'origine
étrangèr il y a des Français de
confession musulmanes donc excusez-moi
arrêtez de dire on est on est plus au
19e siècle comme vous l'avez dit donc
moi ce que je dis Hamza il y a une bonne
gueule voil il a l'air sympathique
j'aiim av
la pas mon
style mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
je veux dire cette vidéo
le le message est dommage effectivement
parce qu'il y a des mots qui font
référence alors vous dites oui c'est
rentré dans les meurs mais pour les
employeurs et pour beaucoup de Français
c'est pas rentré dans les meurs et on a
toujours l'impression que vous voulez
communautariser le discours et vous
victimiser c'est vrai voilà alors qu'en
fait vous avez pas besoin de ça la
France permet tout c'est avec votre
travail avec votre compéten avec votre
mérite voilà donc très clairement gardez
cette ligne là et ne trouvez pas des
bouqu missaires ne vous victimisez pas
de petites secondes avant donner la
parole à gtier juste parce que oui de
petit s bah non il il est pas là il a dû
être arrivé c'est le tout mieux le
restaurant est déjà là-bas il est encore
là merci ça va
bonsoir je vais dire quelque chose que
je vous jour de ne jamais répéter Cyril
aujourd'hui et demain je suis d'accord
avec Gill Verdez non je ne le dir jamais
jamais voilà je dis une fois oui je
voulais juste vous poser une question
est-ce que vous avez pensé porter
plainte parce que si votre
témoignage parce qu'effectivement c'est
totalement convable combi de temps parce
que parce que je suis déjà je suis pas
orgueilleux et puis et puis je le
remercie d'un côté cette personne là
parce que j'ai pu j'ai pu avancer ça ça
m'a forgé voilà aujourd'hui je suis de
plus en plus je suis plus solide j'ai
j'ai je suis plus prêt à accepter
certaines choses et puis ça m'a permis
de de d'avoir une ouverture d'esprit et
de me dire voilà ok c'est c'est présent
c'est là mais faut faire avec et puis je
me je me bats pour ça voilà mê pas par
comme vous avz perdu une jamb car Baga
Carla non mais quand je on on pourrait
retirer vos vos phrases de de son
contexte et on dirait que vous avez
perdu une jambe et que là vous vous en
remettez machin mais pour moi c'est de
la victimisation
la victimis R 2 secondes parce qu'il il
est pas bien mais non non mais mais non
mais parce que entend ce mot
victimisation j'en ai assez parce que
quand on vit des choses et qu'on en
parle on nous dit tout le temps on est
dans la victimisation on n'est pas des
victimes parce que nous quand vous nous
mettez une claque on tend pas l're jour
j'ai pas dit que vous étiez des victimes
c'est on prend les choses à bras le cor
moi j'ai monté ma boîte j'avais 19 ans
parce que j'ai compris le système dans
lequel j'étais j'ai moi je suis rentré
en boî j'avais 19
[Rires]
ans Ben nous onait pas le droit nous
voilà nous on était rejeté à ce
momentl
Plee je n' jamais été dans la ple et
vous me connaissez vous connaissez mes
combats vous savez ce que je transmets
aux jeunes c'est exactement ce discours
là ne vous laissez pas à battre c'est
pas parce que vous avez des handicap que
vous êtes des handicapés c'est pas parce
que vous
avezousam c'est ce qu'on Essie de
transmre je votre discours il dessert ce
que vous normalement vous défendez vous
dites il faut que les gens s'int gens
6000 et cetera on a des jeunes qui font
des études alors vous dites que c'est
pas plus difficile pour eux vous savez
que c'est pas vrai mais c'est pas grave
c'est votre théorie c'est dur aussi
quand on est isolé à la campagne on
nppose pas les choses et là on a des
jeunes qui se battent qui réussissent et
cetera qui portent un témoignage et à
aucun moment j'ai écouté plusieurs fois
la vidéo il est en train de dire que
c'est pour tout le monde pareil et là
vous devriez si vous voulez taper sur
les gens en disant mais non c'est pas
vrai déjà non mais comment vous voulez
remettre en cause des jeunes comme ça
qui se battent et tout moi en fait cont
té endez pas ce que je
dis qu' y a un double s' y a pas besoin
de se battre on a besoin de quoi alors
les chérries j'aimerais juste qu'on ait
quand même la vie d'un témoin extérieur
on va voir et on va voir bien sûr ce
qu'on a pensé le public après on aura la
vie d'un témoin extérieur êtes-vous
d'accord alors c'est pas la peine de
faire une musique comme
ça plus de drame non plus c'est vrai
voilà donc non 45 % oui 54 % c'est voilà
c'est le oui qui l'emporte mais